that's a beautiful thing man
um who would you say where your biggest
influence was growing up you said G Unit
obviously for sure um
um um Dip set of course you know I'm
from Harlem
um
yeah just just them really Dipset and g
in it they're saying G Unit that's why I
watched you know on TV so if you had to
go with one
if you had to let's say you're on an
island you could only take all of the
Dipset discography or all the Geo in the
discography mixtapes included which
which CD book are you taking I'm not
going to be politically correct and say
Harlem I gotta go with your unit cause
that's what made me do it you gotta go
Get Rich or Die Tryin man beg for mercy
you know that's a whole lot beg for
mercy was crazy all the junior radios
and you can include the documentary from
the game in today because that was a Jew
in it album yup I'll go for more Hunger
for More was crazy and even the Young
Buck [ __ ] yeah Buck was hard yeah now
that I I go back and I'll listen and my
vocals even uh the massacre I feel like
gets slept on of course there's so much
good [ __ ] records on there I feel
like the massacre was like somehow
doesn't get enough respect because it
wasn't as big as get rich or die trying
but I'm like yo there was some real
Crazy Rap [ __ ] on there ski mask way
Baltimore love thing shout out to
[ __ ] position of Power Man even
the um
what was the disc record he had piggy
bank was hard damn that [ __ ] was hard
yeah 50 was flagrant back in the day
have you been able to meet him at all
yeah I mean every time I see if I take a
pic with him like it's the first time
yeah you know I just racked my 50 Cent
picks up well have you tried out for the
future oh no not yet I ain't even I
didn't even get a chance to really you
know kick it with him like how I wanted
to but every time I see him I left no
like yo you motivated me to do this [ __ ]
like real I let him know that every time